hi I'm Greg yes hello
then you start it's not ready for that
hey do you know what time it is what
time is the next time for another Iraq
Iraq Oh what the [ __ ] are you serious oh
my god I broke several people on this
channel to watch raka raka you're the
one you're third time in a row we're
watching Iraq Iraq well you know that's
because I appreciate you actually not
really like my video subscribe to
everything I'm like ready so this next
video is called porn police this new
yeah horn please yeah
lord knows you need this
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
Oh God
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
Wow
[Music]
[Music]
oh good old rock record wow that was
hysterical I wasn't expecting I don't
know what I thought I really wasn't
expecting that
that was I just love their John
roebling's man like a SWAT thriller kind
of the execution of it is so well done
how long do you think it takes them to
like film one of these skits I don't
know they upload like like for a two
minutes a week or every other week or
something yeah they uploaded quite often
I could the kind of see porn police
being a thing one day you think that
makes me imagine how like down the road
that my outlaw porn they're never gonna
know that will never be a funny police
will be a porn is not good for you I'm
not saying that it's good or bad for you
I'm just saying I don't ever think it's
gonna get to the level of where I'm not
saying it's good or bad for you either I
just think it's bad for you nah I don't
mind watching porn with someone else
neither do I alone I can just feel like
a loser if I watch about myself I can
watch if I watch it like one day and the
next day I watch it again then I'm like
this is kind of sad I'm just watching
people have sex I'm doing it looking at
a screen and I'm jerking off well I mean
that's it's kind of
normal yeah you know there was a time
where slavery was normal good that mean
it was good might be a little bit
extreme in my argument but it's an
argument but you're right you know it's
the time where black people sitting on
the bus was get up
so just because something's normal is
not necess exactly ain't Gregory thank
you go on a reddit article watch a TED
talks about what porn does to a guy's
mind wonder what it does to a woman's
mind oh that's nothing you guys you guys
don't have anything to worry I don't
think we watch it as regularly as the
gentleman yeah yeah I think it's
something he goes differently guys yeah
yeah when I first sophomore and I it's
all I found like DVDs and I was like 10
years old 10 yeah now 10 year olds or 9
year olds I think now that's crazy
internet pornography has just changed
the game for everybody yeah I remember I
was 15 when I first watched was it what
was it a videotape yeah was a videotape
because I am a decade older we didn't
really have the internet when I was 15
my two younger cousins this is so
[ __ ] weird
they uh they had a porn tape and they're
like do you want to watch this and I'm
like what did what and then they put it
in there like pros they're younger than
me it took three years you're gonna be
[ __ ] I don't even know they put it in
and I'm just sitting there and they're
like just like [ __ ] eatin popcorn and
I'm like oh I was like traumatized by it
I was like this is not supposed to be a
thing that humans do with each other and
now it's just like you know porn is like
whatever I remember like being 15 and
going over my friend's house and they
would have like don t see em these
late-night porn movies where you don't
see like genitals but just like full-on
sex scene you know last like 10 to 15
minutes Wow but you just don't see like
the shadows yeah yeah but it'll just be
like 10 of us just watching a bunch of
you party minun ya know no one's jacking
off you know what's find it weird when
guys watch play I mean like you just
expect a circle jerk at them I know
right it doesn't even happen you're just
harder than one guy step it up a notch
it's 2007 I'm just saying we need porn
police the hue
thank you tonight Trump might watch this
video and go we need this night never
know what can influence that guy never
know subscribe to the rack Arrakis
directory okay you will not be damaged
watch subscribe please subscribe to the
real rejects please subscribe to the
real good Stargazer subscribe to her
channel and shout out to my friend John
Humphrey John Humphrey shout out to you
sir it's all thing what does that even
mean he knows what it means I don't
think it describes John he knows it you
know what I mean I don't know